OUR ENTIRE HOUR TONIGHT.
SO ENJOY.
>> Laura: MR. PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
ON FRIDAY, TED WHEELER, THE
MAYOR OF PORTLAND, SENT A LETTER
TO YOU SAYING BASICALLY WE DON’T
WANT YOUR HELP, YOU MAKE MATTERS
WORSE, SATURDAY, ONE OF HER
SUPPORTERS IS MURDERED IN
PORTLAND BY IT LOOKS LIKE A
SUSPECTED ANTIFA INDIVIDUAL.
AND THEN ON SUNDAY, WHEELER
COMES OUT, AND BIDEN AND
ESSENTIALLY TRIES TO BLAME SHIFT
TO YOU FOR THE VIOLENCE THERE.
YOUR REACTION?
SPEAK OF THESE ARE TERRIBLE AND
VERY INCOMPETENT PEOPLE.
PORTLAND HAS BEEN BURNING FOR
MANY YEARS, FOR DECADES IT’S
BEEN BURNING, BUT NOW IT’S
GOT -- I WATCHED THE MAYOR TRY
AND GET IN WITH THESE PEOPLE AND
HE WENT TO A PROTEST AND THEY
ALMOST KILLED HIM.
IF HE DIDN’T HAVE SECURITY, HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN DEAD, JUST LIKE
THEY WOULD HAVE DONE TO
RAND PAUL, WHO’S A GREAT GUY,
AND HIS WIFE, KELLY.
IT’S A DISGRACE WITH HAPPENING.
WE SENT IN HOMELAND SECURITY.
THE REASON WE SENT THEM AND WAS
TO PROTECT OUR COURTHOUSE.
WE HAVE A $300 MILLION
COURTHOUSE AND THEY WANTED TO
BLOW UP OUR COURTHOUSE OR BURN
IT DOWN.
TAKE YOUR CHOICE, BLOW IT UP OR
BURN IT DOWN, THEY SAID AND I
SAID NO, NO, THAT’S NOT
HAPPENING, SO THEY WOULDN’T
PROTECTED BECAUSE THE MAYOR SAID
HE DOESN’T CARE, SO WE SENT IN
OUR HOMELAND PEOPLE, THEY DID A
GREAT JOB.
IMMEDIATELY HOMELAND SECURITY.
IMMEDIATELY IT WAS PROTECTED,
AND THAT’S THE ONLY REASON THEY
WERE THERE.
I’VE OFFERED TO SEND IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
I’VE OFFERED TO SEND THEM
ANYBODY THEY WANT, I COULD PUT
THAT IN 45 MINUTES AND IT WOULD
STOP.
AND I THINK THE PEOPLE OF
PORTLAND AND THE PEOPLE OF
OREGON, I KNOW IT’S A LIBERAL
STATE, THEY ARE TIRED OF IT.
THEY ARE TIRED OF LIVING WITH
THIS CURSE.
THEY ARE LIVING WITH A CURSE.
THEY SAY THAT WHEN YOU WALK
THROUGH THE STREETS OF PORTLAND,
THIS IS YEARS AND YEARS OF
BURNING --
>> Laura: THE LAST 90 DAYS
IT’S BEEN REALLY --
>> President Trump: IT’S BEEN
HORRIBLE.
BUT IT’S BEEN GOING ON FOR MANY,
MANY, MANY YEARS.
IT’S LIKE -- I WON’T NAME THE
CITY, BUT IT’S A CITY SOMEPLACE
IN THE WORLD THAT’S NOT SO GOOD.
IT’S A TERRIBLE SITUATION.
>> Laura: THE OREGON GOVERNOR
SAID NO ONE IS SAFE AND
DONALD TRUMP ’US AMERICA.
THEY’RE TRYING TO TURN THE
TABLES ON YOU AFTER MONTHS OF --
THEY ARE NOT REALLY SAYING MUCH
OF NOT TO THE VIOLENCE.
>> President Trump: BUT THEY
WON’T REALLY CRITICIZE ANYBODY
THAT’S A VIOLENT PERSON, THEY
STICK UP FOR THE VIOLENCE.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE GETTING
HURT, THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THESE
PEOPLE.
IT’S A WEIRD THING, IT’S LIKE
WARPED MINDS AND FOR THE LAST 93
DAYS, I’VE BEEN OFFERING TO
SEND -- AS YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE
TO TAKE THE OFFER.
THEY HAVE TO ASK TO HAVE HELP.
I’VE BEEN STANDING AND I’VE BEEN
SAYING ANYTIME YOU’RE READY --
>> Laura: WHAT’S MOTIVATING
THEM, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> President Trump: I THINK
IT’S A SICKNESS.
I THINK IT’S FEAR.
THE WAY THEY TREATED THIS MAYOR,
WHEELER, WHEN HE WAS STANDING
THERE AND I’LL TELL YOU HOW
UNFAIR THE NEWS IS.
NBC NEWS DIDN’T SHOW THAT HE WAS
BEING SHOUTED AT AND CURSED AT
AND HE RAN -- LITERALLY HAD TO
RUN FOR HIS LIFE BECAUSE THEY
WERE GOING TO REALLY HURT HIM.
HE HAD SECURITY, IF HE DIDN’T --
>> Laura: THEY SHOWED UP AT
HIS APARTMENT BUILDING.
>> President Trump: HOW HE CAN
STILL STICK UP FOR HIM, I THINK
THERE IS A FEAR, AFRAID.
>> Laura: ARE THEY AFRAID THAT
OREGON COULD BE IN PLAY BECAUSE
OF PEOPLE’S CONCERN ABOUT LAW
AND ORDER, IS THAT WHAT YOU’RE
SAYING?
>> President Trump: I THINK
LIKE THE MAYOR, I THINK IS
PROBABLY AFRAID FOR HIS LIFE
BECAUSE IF YOU WOULD HAVE SEEN
HIM BUT I WILL SHOW YOU HOW
DISHONEST, NBC NEWS PUT ON --
AND THEY DIDN’T HAVE THE PEOPLE
SHOUTING, THEY HAD THEM STANDING
THERE AND THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW
IT WAS A SHOW OF GREAT UNITY,
THE MAYOR STANDING WITH THE
PEOPLE.
THEY WERE SAYING THINGS THAT I
CAN’T REPEAT RIGHT NOW, BUT
HORRIBLE THINGS, BUT THEY DIDN’T
PUT THAT ON.
I ACTUALLY HAPPENED TO SEE THE
REAL TAPE ON FOX.
HE ESCAPED WITH HIS LIFE AND YET
HE DOESN’T WANT ANY HELP.
IT’S SO UNFAIR TO THE PEOPLE OF
OREGON.
WE COULD SOLVE THE PROBLEM
QUICKLY, LIKE I DID IN KENOSHA.
YOU KNOW KENOSHA WENT THROUGH
THREE OR FOUR DAYS -- YOU
WOULDN’T HAVE A KENOSHA RIGHT
NOW.
WE DEMANDED THAT THEY SEND IN
THE NATIONAL GUARD, CALL THE
GOVERNOR, AND IN ALL FAIRNESS,
THE GOVERNOR DID IT.
NOT ENOUGH, BUT IT WAS ENOUGH TO
PUT IT OUT AND WE ULTIMATELY PUT
IN -- WE HAD A THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND WE PUT IT OUT QUICKLY.
YOU WOULDN’T HAVE KENOSHA RIGHT
NOW.
>> Laura: IN PITTSBURGH TODAY,
JOE BIDEN GAVE A SPEECH AND HE
SPOKE DIRECTLY ABOUT THIS
VIOLENCE.
>> HE MAY BELIEVE THE WORDS LAW
AND ORDER MAKES THEM STRONG, BUT
HIS FAILURE TO CALL ON HIS OWN
SUPPORTERS TO STOP ACTING AS AN
ARMED MILITIA IN THIS COUNTRY
SHOWS HOW WEAK HE IS.
>> Laura: YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT?
>> President Trump: LOOK, HE’S
A WEAK PERSON, HE’S BEEN WEAK
ALL HIS LIFE BUT NOW HE’S REALLY
WEAK.
HE SHOULDN’T BE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, HE SHOULD NOT BE
THERE --
>> Laura: BUT DO YOU WANT YOUR
SUPPORTERS TO CONFRONT THE
LEFT-WING PROTESTERS OR DO YOU
WANT TO LEAVE IT TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT?
>> President Trump: I WANT TO
LEAVE IT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT
MY SUPPORTERS ARE WONDERFUL,
HARDWORKING, TREMENDOUS PEOPLE
AND THEY TURN ON THEIR
TELEVISIONS AND THEY LOOK AT A
PORTLAND OR A KENOSHA BEFORE I
GOT INVOLVED AND STOPPED IT.
OR THEY LOOK AT CHICAGO WERE 78
PEOPLE WERE SHOT LAST WEEKEND
AND NUMEROUS PEOPLE DIED, OR
THEY LOOK AT NEW YORK WHERE
VIOLENCE IS UP BY, WHAT, 150%.
IT’S UP BY A NUMBER -- AND
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING.
THEY’RE LOOKING AT ALL OF THIS
AND THEY CAN’T BELIEVE IT.
THEY CAN’T BELIEVE IT.
WHETHER IT’S MY SUPPORTERS ARE
NOT.
>> Laura: YOU DON’T WANT THEM
SHOWING --
>> President Trump: IT’S A
PEACEFUL PROTEST.
THEY WERE PROTESTING.
YOU KNOW IT’S AMAZING.
THEY WANT A PROTEST AND THEY GET
CRITICIZED.
THE OTHER PEOPLE RUN THROUGH THE
STREETS, BURNED-OUT STOREFRONTS,
BEAT PEOPLE AND KILL PEOPLE,
KICK PEOPLE IN THE FACE, THAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED TO RAND PAUL
BY THE WAY AND HIS WIFE AND THEN
YOU HAD TO GO AND ULTIMATELY
FORGO VERY GOOD POLICEMAN WHO
TOOK A BIG BEATING.
THEY TOOK A BIG BEATING AND THEY
REALLY SAVED RAND PAUL.
WE ARE GOING TO BRING HIM INTO
THE WHITE HOUSE AND GIVE HIM
SOME KIND OF ACCOMMODATION
BECAUSE THEY REALLY -- WHAT THEY
DID WAS VERY BRAVE, ACTUALLY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THEM SAYING
POLICEMAN WERE BRAVE BECAUSE
THEY WERE ESCORTING, BUT THEY
ARE ESCORTING A U.S. SENATOR AND
HIS WIFE AND AS HE SAID, HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN KILLED IF THEY
WEREN’T THERE.
SPEEONE’S INDENTURE ALSO,
MR. PRESIDENT THAT DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN IN THEIR OWN WAY
INCITING THIS VIOLENCE AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS IS ALMOST AS LONG AS
YOU’VE BEEN IN OFFICE.
>> IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET, YOU GET OUT AND YOU
[INDISCERNIBLE] AND YOU TELL
THEM THEY ARE NOT WELCOME
ANYMORE ANYWHERE.
>> PLEASE, GET UP IN THE FACE OF
SOME CONGRESSPEOPLE.
>> THERE NEEDS TO BE UNREST IN
THE STREET.
>> THE DOMESTIC ENEMIES OF OUR
VOTING SYSTEM AND AREN’T
HONORING OUR CONSTITUTION RIGHT
AT 1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE WITH
THEIR ALLIES IN THE CONGRESS OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> President Trump: IT’S NOT
ONLY THE DEMOCRATS, IT’S THE
MEDIA.
THE FAKE NEWS.
THE NEWS IS SO FAKE.
THE MAYOR, WHERE THEY MAKE IT
LOOK LIKE IT’S A GREAT UNITY
THING WHEN ACTUALLY THEY WERE
CURSING AT HIM AND THEY WOULD
HAVE DONE BIG NUMBERS, BUT THEY
DON’T SHOW THAT, THEY SHOW THE
MAYOR STANDING WITH THESE VERY
TOUGH THUGS AND HE WAS GOD,
OKAY?
THEY SAVED HIM.
NBC SHOWS THAT LIKE IT’S UNITY
WITH THE PEOPLE.
I DON’T GET IT, I DON’T KNOW WHY
THEY’RE DOING IT AND I WILL SAY
THIS.
AT SOME POINT, I WILL NOT BE
PRESIDENT.
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL BE IN FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW, BUT I WILL NOT
BE PRESIDENT AND THEY’RE GOING
TO DIE, THEY’RE ALL GOING TO
DIE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THEY HAD TO
COVER SLEEPY JOE BIDEN?
IT WON’T BE VERY MUCH FUN, BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, OUR COUNTRY
WOULD GO TO HELL, OUR
STOCKMARKET WORK CRASH AND
ASSURANCE ARE SITTING THERE, WE
WILL HAVE PROBLEMS LIKE WE’VE
NEVER HAD BUT IF YOU TAKE
KENOSHA AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THAT I DON’T EVEN TALK
ABOUT -- I COULD SHOW YOU THINGS
THAT WE’VE DONE TO STOP THIS
KIND OF A THING THAT’S HAPPENING
IN PORTLAND AND HAPPENING IN
CHICAGO AND HAPPENING IN OTHER
PLACES.
>> Laura: MOST RED STATES ARE
COOPERATING AND THINGS ARE
RELATIVELY CALM IN RED STATE
AMERICA, BUT BIDEN SAID AGAIN
TODAY IN PITTSBURGH THAT
ESSENTIALLY YOU’RE NOT GOING TO
BE SAFE IN DONALD TRUMP’S
AMERICA.
>> President Trump: SO, IF IT
WEREN’T DONALD TRUMP’S AMERICA,
TO JUST USE THE EXPRESSION AS ON
PRESIDENT, YOU WOULD HAVE RIOTS
LIKE YOU’VE NEVER SEEN.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE LOST CONTROL
OF THE RADICAL LEFT AND IF YOU
LOOK AT BERNIE AND -- I CALL IT
THE MANIFESTO THAT WAS AGREED TO
WITH BIDEN, THAT’S FURTHER LEFT
THAN BERNIE EVER WAS.
IT WON’T BE ABLE TO CONTROL
THESE PEOPLE.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE LOST CONTROL
OF THESE PEOPLE AND THAT’S
HURTING THEM.
DON’T FORGET, BIDEN WASN’T GOING
TO COME OUT OF HIS BASEMENT
UNTIL THE ELECTION.
NOW HE HAD TO BECAUSE THE POLLS
ARE SO GOOD FOR ME.
ARE DIFFERENT, SO ALL OF A
SUDDEN HE’S IN PITTSBURGH.
HE WASN’T GOING TO LEAVE HIS
BASEMENT, THEN HE SAID OKAY,
HE’S LEAVING, BUT HE WON’T LEAVE
FOR TEN DAYS.
TEN DAYS IS A LONG TIME, SO IN
THE MEANTIME LIKE ON SUNDAY AND
SO IS SATURDAY, I’M IN TEXAS,
I’M IN LOUISIANA.
I WAS GOING TO STOP IN TWO OTHER
PLACES, ARKANSAS WASN’T HIT VERY
MUCH, ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
I WOULD HAVE STOPPED, BUT I’M
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
I LEAVE EARLY IN THE MORNING, I
GET LAID HOME AT NIGHT AND
THAT’S WHAT DO HAVE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: TOMORROW YOU’RE
GOING TO KENOSHA, WISCONSIN, THE
SCENE OF SO MUCH UNREST LATELY.
AND THE GOVERNOR SAYS HE DOESN’T
WANT YOU TO COME.
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
BE SEEN BY THE PEOPLE OF
WISCONSIN NOW?
>> President Trump: BECAUSE I
AM A TREMENDOUS FAN OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND I WANT TO
THANK THE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY’VE DONE A GOOD JOB AND WHEN
THE GOVERNOR SAYS THAT I
SHOULDN’T COME, OR THAT HE WOULD
PREFER THAT I DON’T COME.
I’M THE ONE THAT CALLED AND SAID
TONY, YOU’VE GOT TO BRING UP THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
I DON’T REALLY WANT TO DO IT.
TONY, YOU’VE GOT TO BRING IT OUT
AND UNLIKE YOUR GOVERNOR OF
OREGON, THAT JUST KEEP SAYING
NO, HE AGREED TO IT.
HE AGREED TO A SMALL NUMBER BUT
THE SMALL NUMBER WAS PLENTY.
>> Laura: ISN’T IT POLITICAL
MOTIVATION?
THEY DON’T WANT TO COME TO BOOST
IN AMERICA BECAUSE THEY DON’T
WANT THE MEDIA TO HAVE TO COVER
WHAT’S REALLY HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND.
ISN’T THIS POLITICAL?
>> President Trump: BLUE STATE
AMERICA, BLUE CITY AMERICA, YOU
LOOK AT WHAT’S GOING ON IN
NEW YORK, YOU LOOK AT WHAT’S
GOING ON IN THE STATES, CHICAGO
IS A DISASTER.
PORTLAND, YOU LOOK AT PORTLAND
AND PORTLAND IS LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
THAT’S ANARCHISTS AND I ACTUALLY
THINK IN MANY WAYS THAT’S EASIER
TO HANDLE.
I THINK PORTLAND IS VERY EASY TO
HANDLE BECAUSE THAT’S A GROUP OF
ANARCHISTS THAT ARE PAID BY THE
OUTSIDE AND YOU KNOW, WE PUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN JAIL.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU KNOW THIS A
OR NOT.
THREE OR FOUR MONTHS AGO WE HAD
A PROBLEM WITH MONUMENTS.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS DIDN’T SAY
ANYTHING.
>> President Trump: ACTUALLY
GOT OUT OF CONTROL EVEN FOR
THEM.
I SIGNED IN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER,
TEN YEARS IN JAIL IF YOU KNOCKED
ON A STATUE OR MONUMENT.
YOU HAVEN’T HEARD ONE THING
ABOUT IT.
WE WOULDN’T HAVE -- THEY WERE
GOING AFTER THOMAS JEFFERSON.
THERE WERE GOING AFTER LINCOLN
AND THEY WERE GOING AFTER THE TH
WASHINGTON MONUMENT.
AND I ACTUALLY DON’T EVEN THINK
THEY KNOW.
I THINK THEY’RE JUST THUGS.
IT MAY BE AN IDEOLOGY, AND IT
MAY NOT.
IT IS AN IDEOLOGY FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE PAYING THEM AND THE
FUNNY THING IS AND THE STRANGE
THING IS, THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PAYING THEM ALL THIS MONEY
BECAUSE SUMMIT IS DOING IT --
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE
CORPORATIONS?
SPEECH OF THE PEOPLE PAYING
THEM, THEIR LIVES WILL BE TAKEN
AWAY, THEIR LIVES WILL BE IN
DANGER.
THEY’RE ALL GOING TO BE GONE,
THEY ARE JUST STUPID FOOLISH
PEOPLE THAT MADE A LOT OF MONEY.
>> Laura: CORPORATIONS HAVE
GIVEN AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS TO
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
WHICH IS ALL OVER A LOT OF THESE
PROTESTS.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN ABOUT
THESE CORPORATIONS, WHY ARE THEY
PAYING THAT MONEY OUT?
>> President Trump: BECAUSE
THEY ARE WEAK PEOPLE.
MANY CASES.
>> Laura: WEEK PEOPLE?
>> President Trump: HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS --
>> Laura: WHEN YOU SAY THERE
WEEK, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> President Trump: THEY JUST
DO WHAT’S THE EASIEST PATH.
THAT’S A VERY DANGEROUS PATH.
BLACK LIVES MATTER IS A MARXIST
ORGANIZATION.
YOU REMEMBER PIGS IN A BLANKET,
FRY THEM LIKE BACON.
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME I EVER
HEARD OF BLACK LIVES MATTER.
I SAID THAT’S A TERRIBLE NAME,
IT’S SO DISCRIMINATORY.
IT’S BAD FOR BLACK PEOPLE, IT’S
BAD FOR EVERYBODY AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN IT BECOMES LIKE SORT
OF -- ALTHOUGH NOW IF YOU LOOK,
IT’S GONE WAY DOWN BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF THIS STUFF,
WHAT’S GOING ON, IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT’S GOING OVER THE BATS AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF THUGS.
>> Laura: D.C. LAST NIGHT.
>> President Trump: IT’S
TERRIBLE WHAT’S GOING ON, BUT
BLACK LIVES MATTER CAME INTO
EXISTENCE WALKING DOWN THE
STREET SCREAMING "PIGS IN A
BLANKET, FRY THEM LIKE BACON"
AND THAT WAS ABOUT POLICE
OFFICERS.
THAT WAS REPRESENTING POLICE.
THEY WERE PIGS.
PIGS IN A BLANKET LIKE THE
SAUSAGES OR HOT DOGS.
>> Laura: [INDISCERNIBLE] IT’S
GOTTEN --
>> President Trump: DID IT GET
WORSE?
>> Laura: DOJ’S ROLE IN TRYING
TO REALLY HIT THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACCELERATOR HERE
AGAINST THESE GROUPS, A LOT OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS COMING INTO
WISCONSIN HAVE BEEN TRACKED AS
OUT-OF-STATE, THE ONES WHO HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED.
CAN DOJ DO MORE -- WHAT COULD
THEY DO TO REALLY START PUTTING
THE FEAR OF GOD IN THESE
VIOLENT -- NOT THE PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS, BUT VIOLENT
PROTESTERS?
>> President Trump: THEY HAVE
UNDER INVESTIGATION -- I WILL
SHOW YOU.
I HAD THIS BECAUSE OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT INTERVIEW WITH YOU, I
WILL GIVE THIS TO YOU,
KANSAS CITY, VIOLENCE HAS
DECREASED BY A THIRD SINCE THE
INITIATIVE BEGAN AND
INDIANAPOLIS, GUNS CONFISCATED,
MORE THAN 1,000 ARRESTS HAVE
BEEN MADE ON THE INITIATIVE.
DOJ IS ADDRESSING VIOLENCE AND
CRIME ACROSS THE COUNTRY, BUT
YOU DON’T READ THAT.
THE FBI AND ATF ARE ASSISTING
THE PORTLAND POLICE DEPARTMENT,
YOU CAN’T DO MUCH WHEN YOU HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO COOPERATION.
>> Laura: IF THEY DON’T THINK
THEY’RE GOING TO GO TO JAIL FOR
TEN YEARS FOR DOING WHAT THEY’RE
DOING, THEN THEY’RE GOING TO
KEEP DOING IT, SO HOW DOES A
TRUMP REELECTION CALM THINGS
DOWN IN THE UNITED STATES?
BIDEN SAYS IT WILL CALM THINGS
DOWN, HOW WILL THE TRUMP
ELECTION CALM THINGS DOWN?
WHY WON’T HE CALM THINGS DOWN?
>> President Trump: THEY WON’T
CALM THINGS DOWN, THEY WILL TAKE
OVER.
IF BIDEN GETS AND THEY WILL HAVE
WON.
HE’S A WEAK PERSON, HE’S
CONTROLLED LIKE A PUPPET.
IT’S NOT GOING TO CALM THINGS
DOWN, IT’S GOING TO BE THEY WILL
HAVE WON.
THEY WILL HAVE TAKEN OVER YOUR
CITIES.
IT’S A REVOLUTION, YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT’S A REVOLUTION AND THE PEOPLE
OF THIS COUNTRY WILL NOT STAND
FOR THAT.
IF THEY’RE NOT GOING TO STAND
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE ME.
EVERY TIME I PUT "LAW & ORDER"
UP ON SOCIAL MEDIA, IT GETS SUCH
AN INCREDIBLE POSITIVE RESPONSE.
THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY WILL
NOT STAND FOR IT.
IF YOU SAY CALM THINGS DOWN,
YEAH, CALM THINGS DOWN BECAUSE
THEY WILL HAVE TAKEN OVER.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT’S GOING ON.
BIDEN IS -- I DON’T EVEN LIKE TO
MENTION BIDEN BECAUSE HE’S NOT
CONTROLLING ANYTHING.
>> Laura: WHO DO YOU THINK IS
PULLING HIS STRINGS?
IS A FORMER OBAMA OFFICIALS?
>> President Trump: PEOPLE
YOU’VE NEVER HEARD OF, PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THE DARK SHADOWS.
>> Laura: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN,
THAT SOUNDS LIKE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
>> President Trump: PEOPLE YOU
HAVEN’T HEARD OF.
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE STREETS,
PEOPLE THAT ARE CONTROLLING THE
STREETS.
WE HAD SOME TO GET ON A PLANE
FROM A CERTAIN CITY AND IN THE
PLANE IT ALMOST COMPLETELY
LOADED WITH DOGS WEARING THESE
DARK UNIFORMS, BLACK UNIFORMS
WITH GEAR AND THIS AND THAT,
THEY ARE ON A PLANE.
I WILL TELL YOU SOMETIME, BUT
IT’S UNDER INVESTIGATION RIGHT
NOW.
BUT THEY CAME FROM A CERTAIN
CITY AND THIS PERSON WAS COMING
TO THE REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
CONVENTION.
THERE WERE LIKE SEVEN PEOPLE IN
THE PLANE LIKE THIS PERSON AND
THEN A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE IN THE
PLANE TO DO BIG DAMAGE.
>> Laura: PLANNING FOR
WASHINGTON.
>> President Trump: THIS IS
ALL HAPPENING.
>> Laura: BUT THE MONEY IS
COMING FROM SOMEWHERE.
HOW CAN IT BE TRACKED?
>> President Trump: SOME VERY
STUPID RICH PEOPLE THAT HAVE NO
IDEA THAT IF THERE THING EVER